It's time for me to run another comprehensive metabolic panel for my
Joe Tippen's protocol
But I've been sick since Friday with an upper respiratory gunk. I've managed to avoid antibiotics and I'm getting better
But still weak. I'm assuming this illness will potentially throw off some of the numbers
So I'm putting it off going in for the draw. How long should I wait?
Is like the day after I resume normal daily activities? Okay, or should this
Should I give this more time to get it more? We need full results
No, I think you should do it when you're sick. So
Why would I do it when you're sick? Okay, if you have a bacterial infection or a viral infection
We'll be able to get a fairly good discernment if you run this test
So
If you have a bacterial infection or a viral infection, it should not affect your
Again, why am I asking
For a complete metabolic panel
Comprehensive metabolic panel when a person is doing the Joe Tippen's protocol
It's this question right here. What does it mean when my AST is elevated?
So if I'm using Ben Medizol, that's the Joe Tippen's protocol. If I'm using Ben Medizol, it has the potential
Of congested my liver
How would I know that because I'm going to run a comprehensive metabolic panel
And I'm going to see an elevation of my AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase. So I better
Calm down on my Joe Tippen's protocol. Maybe I'm going to pause it for a little bit
It infection won't do that
So don't not get this test done when you have an infection
You have respiratory upper respiratory infection
That's not going to affect your AST and ALT and alkaline phosphatase
And if you do it when you have the infection
We're going to get a clue because the other thing that's done
Hopefully you're not just doing a complete metabolic panel. You're doing a
CBC with differential. So if you're doing a CBC with differential, we'll be able to see
If you have an infection most likely if it's a really nasty infection your white blood cell count will be elevated
And then when we look at the differential of the white blood cell count
We'll be able to see are the lymphocytes elevated. Oh, it's probably a viral infection
So it'll give you clues to okay then treat it as a viral infection
Maybe run the the right viral program on it
Or if is your lymphocytes actually suppressed but your neutrophils are
Are elevated then it's probably a bacterial infection then run the bacterial programs
And maybe take some specific
Supplements like activation of things that would be good for bacteria
So it can be beneficial to get the test done when you're ill
It's not going to your illness if it's an infection. It's not going to affect the liver numbers
So make sure you get a CMP and a CBC with differential so we can get a better idea of what's going on in your lungs
So you'll be able to better treat that